begin this morning with a new
development in russia's five weeks-long
war against ukraine
as ukrainian forces reclaim more
territories running its capital kiev
president vladimir zelinsky is not
saying whether he gave the order for a
russian fuel depot to be struck on
friday russia was quick to accuse
ukraine for the attack ukraine denies
responsibility for it but if confirmed
it would be the first time that
ukrainian aircraft had crossed into
russian airspace
in a separate development the us will
provide an additional 300 million
dollars in military equipment to
ukrainian forces deborah patta is in
keeve with the latest on plans to get
civilians out of a key city in
southeastern ukraine and on the
relentless russian offensive deborah
good morning
good morning russia is sending more
troops as reinforcements to the donbass
region which has already seen sustained
bombardment for over a month in places
like mario paul and today another red
cross convoy will attempt to evacuate
more residents from the port city which
has been under siege for over five weeks
shell shocked and depleted civilians
evacuated from the eastern front finally
arrive in ukrainian-controlled territory
around 6 000 people half from mariapool
came on red cross buses the young and
the old who've endured more horror in
one month than many bear in a lifetime
there are still more than 150 000
residents left inside unable or
unwilling to leave as russian tanks
continue to pound what's left of their
city
as each new day begins more tears and
heartbreak grief stricken helena is
burying her son vlad lutoff who died on
the battlefield
we were not just a mother and son we
were soul mates she said there are no
words left to say
closer to the capital ukrainians have
pushed the russians back reclaiming
towns including urban where one of the
most important battles of this war was
fought but it has come at a heavy price
leaving a trail of death along the road
to kiev and ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky has warned his people not to
return there yet
the russians are mining the entire
territory houses roads even the bodies
of those killed he said there are so
many trip wires and other dangers from
soldiers like sergey defending kiev only
contempt for russia's claim it has
dramatically reduced operations near the
capital do you believe russia
no i don't believe maybe it's just a
retreat he told us in preparation for a
stronger attack
sergey last picked up a gun 25 years ago
during his conscription
in a few weeks his son turns 18 and will
join him in the fight
russian brutality
serving only to strengthen their resolve
here in kiev there is relief that
ukraine has managed to halt russia's
advance on the capital for now but
they're not getting down their guard as
many here are convinced it could be
short-lived for cbs saturday morning
deborah powder kiev ukraine
tomorrow on face the nation here on cbs
we'll hear from ukrainian president
vladimir zielinski
perez